have you ever played an MMO I'll be
honest I haven't or at least not past
the first five hours oh so now it's not
like I've actively avoided playing these
games I've just always been a little bit
wary of getting sucked into one which I
know is a bit rich from the guy who's
put hundreds of hours into both oblivion
and then Skyrim my point though is that
MMOs have had a lot of bad press over
the years in particular world Warcraft
get new stories about addiction Facebook
groups or wonderfully funny episodes of
South Park you can just you can just
hang outside in the Sun all day tossing
a ball around or you can sit at your
computer and do something that matters
but are they actually this potentially
life crippling force and with likely
millions of people right now jumping
into another MMO experience in the form
of the Elder Scrolls online there seems
like the ideal time to investigate
I think the reason why people perceive
Emma moans to have a negative influence
is often that they are primarily
violence based most of the problems of
the games presented with are solved by
killing your enemies secondly they can
occupy a disproportionate amount of
people's time it's hardly surprising
that something which is enjoyable can
come to take over much of your life I
don't think ever modes are distinct from
any other activity like that I don't
think necessarily the outcomes of
spending a lot of time in the virtual
environment are inherently harmful it's
always a question of what you're missing
out on now we all know of people who
spend a disproportionate amount of their
time on some activity not necessarily
games it could be working out at the gym
watching TV shows or hell even just
browsing Facebook but kid games perhaps
be predisposed towards this more than
other activities video games have many
more opportunities to create
environments situations reward
structures achievement structures which
are almost designed to make you want to
continue playing now that obviously has
a positive side we enjoy it and to the
extent that we can get positive
experiences now put some video games
that's a good thing but it also has a
negative side in that it can come too
preoccupied you it can make you think
about these things when you're not doing
them and to spend as much of your free
time as you can doing them you must
rescue me
and I in turn must rescue you so I don't
know as I guess or a bit of a
double-edged sword a one hand the things
that make them fun are also the things
that engrossing hook you in and perhaps
encourage you to play more than you
shoot but what about some straight-up
positive reasons to play MMOs
do they exist beyond just the fun
gameplay experience there are some very
interesting potential positive outputs
are playing an MMO what online
environments and mmo's offer is an
environment where you can engage in
social interactions with people first of
all who you've never met before but
secondly mmo's can offer a way of
interacting in an interesting way with
people that you know and love without
actually having to travel a long
distance to meet them another key aspect
of MMOs is that generally some of the
great
challenges in the game cannot be
accomplished alone so there is an
inherent way in which teamwork is
required people can duck into or out of
this as they wish but majority players
at some point will engage in a
team-based activity where they all play
a particular role and if they play the
role well then they can accomplish the
activity if I don't play the role well
then they'll probably fail we know that
several organizations use cooperation in
MMOs to actually train people in
leadership and teamwork okay but working
together with friends or strangers
online in an MMO be it plundering caves
taking down bosses or just exploring the
world is not the same as hanging out in
the real world it's a different social
dynamic however one advantage that the
confines of an MMO like World of
Warcraft or the Elder Scrolls online
gives you mark argues is control over
who you are when we encounter each other
in the real world there are lots of
things that we're not in control of
we're not in control of the way we look
and we're not in control of the way we
sound now arguably these are not the
real you these are not the the facets of
your personality that actually matter
but they have a profound influence on
the sorts of interactions we have we
know that the appearance of an avatar in
an MMO will actually affect your
responses to it but the key things are
you're in charge of that you can decide
how you look that's something you're not
offered in the real world the real world
in some sense is very impoverished
because you cannot present who you
really are
without people making judgments before
you get within 10 feet of them now
character customization doesn't just
stop a hair skin color facial structure
and so on
MMOs also give you control over gender
and this can also have a potentially
positive impact on gender selection and
gender representation in games somewhat
of a hot topic in this industry to say
the least I think many video games are
still based around a male protagonist so
it's not to say that this is if this is
a problem or an issue that's been
universally solved but I think within
mmo's it has pretty much always been the
case that you have complete freedom of
choice regardless of the sex of your
character your abilities your status
your standing were completely equal
there's something called the Lara
phenomenon which is arises from the Tomb
Raider games with Lara Croft who is a
strong female lead character it's been
suggested that the availability of
strong female characters and of course
these are almost always available within
mmo's attracts women to gaming they can
explore what it's like to be a powerful
independent individual in a particular
environment
well I think from chatting to mark it's
clear that while MMO certainly have the
potential to suck people in and compel
them to spend a lot of time in those
worlds they create there's also lots of
social and self-fulfilling benefits
- I think Emma moans can redress some of
the challenges we face in the 21st
century if we see and learn that making
social links with people that talking to
strangers isn't nearly as scary or as
threatening as we might be led to
believe then that can make a positive
difference I think they can offer us
environments where our endeavors are
rewarded and I think that can build
resilience if we see and learn that
keeping going is a value then we can
apply that in the real world so you've
heard from Mark and for me but what do
you guys think about mmo's do you play
them have you ever got sucked in would
you like to see reality check do an
episode focused entirely on video game
addiction let me know your thoughts
last week on reality check I explored a
new piece of research which suggested
that playing video games could actually
improve your overall social life now
there are some great comments like this
one from ABS BL who said I honestly
believe that online games like World of
Warcraft help me boost my confidence
when meeting new people as well as
develop a thicker skin when it comes to
dealing with criticism on the other hand
spy Beck commented like I said when this
study was reported by gaming news sites
this isn't a big enough pool it depends
on the genre chosen and of course MMOs
are going to show more social trends
because that's the point of MMOs and
land parties it's like the equivalent of
studying athletes and then looking just
at golf players plus I got some more
great suggestions for future episodes of
the show which I'm adding to the list
but
one from Andrew ice shard who suggested
try making a video on flying cars or
levitation and there's other one from
nature LTF who said you should really do
reality check on cloud-based gaming to
get in touch and let me know what you
think just leave me a comment in the box
down below on GameSpot or YouTube or hit
me up on Twitter at cam phrase Rob see
you next week guys